monsieur du snap vous allez mettre votre
doigt la sur l'emploi d'ici là voilà bon
je m'entends casimir bonjour à monsieur
du snob je suis bien content de vous
voir
ah bon c'est étonnant oui j'ai fait un
peu drôle de rêve et j'aimerais vous en
parler un coup d'oeil mais je n'ai pas
de temps à perdre a écouté des drm de
casimir us je vous assure que ça ne
manque pas d'intérêt ah bon est-ce que
des mandats cherrad me voilà oui j'irai
vite le curieux petits du âge as tu sais
que j'ai étudié la question de près oui
je connais les nuages parker un bon ce
n'est qu'un nuage tout à fait charmant
oui j'entends bien casimir mais il faut
me parler de sa forme ses couleurs ah
oui et bien ils étaient 1
c'était un petit nuage gris gris souris
oui
- écoute casimir je vais t'aider viens
au tableau je vais te montrer à 20 je ne
demande pas mieux oui je vais te montrer
il ya quatre sortes de nuages alors
regard de bien je te les montres et 4 tu
essaieras de reconnaître ton nuage
pour le premier c'est le cirrus le cyrus
c'est un nuage comme ça on dirait des
laits des petites plumes loi ils
annoncent souvent la pluie
non non non mon nuage n'était pas ça a
ainsi reçu ces pains sirugue bon alors
on se dit ah le stratus alors le le
stratus
c'est un nuage comme ça ils étaient des
filaments c'est tout contenu non non
c'est mon nuage était beaucoup plus
simple que ça donc beaucoup plus alors
il ya le le nimbus
as tu connais le lin but la professeure
non le nuage venu à nos bus alors c'est
un nuage de gris qui annonce la pluie à
il est comme ça voilà on n'a rien à voir
rien n'a pas connu un rebond alors le 4e
et le dernier c'est le cumul
ça le cumulus tu connais le cumulus
cumulus et un nuage blanc tout seul dans
le ciel le ciel est bleu tu vois et bien
nuageux tout arrondis comme ça précise
immo précisément ce n'était pas le mien
c'est pas non plus je te passe tous les
laits stratocumulus mais que mulhouse
nimbus mamad mourir aussi 90 sanaryens
rares monnuage terre un petit nuage tout
simple bon écoute alors tu demanderas
quelqu'un le dos parce que moi je n'ai
pas de temps à perdre et moi non plus
il est incroyable mais c'est un casting
que se passe-t-il en fonçant suis bien
content de te voir
voilà j'ai rêvé et donc d'un petit nuage
qui ne voulait pas se transformer en
pluie mais c'est surprenant c'est
casimir mai mais tous les nuages se
transformer en pluie
bah je suis désolé mais pas celui là non
c'était un petit nuage il ne voulait pas
devenir de la pluie que ces murs je ne
comprends rien à touristes
c'est pour qu'un vrai le facteur qui
arrive peut être un facteur de division
bonjour bonjour mes amis acteurs nous
avons un grave problème et casimir à
rêver d'un petit nuage qui ne savait
rien de la pluie est au courant vous a
obtenu âges vous savez moi moi je suis
toujours plus ou moins dans les nuages
alors là dessus je ne peux rien vous
dire mais les moi de la pluie et non pas
du beau temps le bouton me déplaît et
j'en ai même
ils ont casimir tu devrais aller
demander à julie elle s'est peut-être
nollywood c'était là la première
personne à qui il avait demandé
julie je dis si je ne mets tels que cela
je veux vrai que tu m'explique je rêvais
d'un petit nuage
il ne voulait pas se transformer en
pluie etc qui se compensent savamment il
ya sa maman s'appelle la mer du nord et
elle l'appelait très fort elle voulait
qu'il la rejoigne
et lui ne voulait pas très têtu il
restait un petit nuage
casimir je crois que c'est un petit
nuage très heureux qui est très content
d'être dans le ciel et qui n'a pas du
tout envie de fleuret c'est tout ce fric
sans ça c'est touche pas j'ai raconté
hier à casimir l'histoire du petit nuage
qui ne voulaient pas pleurer et il en a
rêvé fait c'est ça c'est une star tu as
raconté hier oui enfin maintenant j'ai
appris des tas de choses c'est très bien
le soir quand je pourrai pas dormir au
lieu d'un de compter les moutons et bien
le contrat gui nuage 1000 us and abuse
ainsi russe mais en fait si on lui ça
cyrus c6 lave si cela c'est qu'ils se
nettoie si ce n'est toi c'est donc ton
frère
[Musique]